what do you guys think is real
the hardest shot in this film right here
that shot right there
hi welcome back to another episode of
vfx artist react today we're going to
show you
some really cool vfx and a couple of not
so cool vfx
clinton ireland so we're joined by sam
today hey my name's sam and i'll be your
beatis
companion anytime you're watching the
beattis of a movie just call me up and
i'll
give you a tip explain what's happening
so we're going to kick off this video
with one of the most requested movies
that we've ever seen in the comments
section
and it also won our patreon poll elita
battle angel
so i actually really enjoyed this movie
it was really fun kind of kind of wonky
but very fun look at that facial
animation
so honestly when this shot came up on
screen i literally said out loud i was
like
wow because it was very realistic even
regardless of the big eyes it was very
real
look how dilated the pupils are like
look how much
light is going into those eyeballs what
is the actual like canonical lore
between having
big eyes is that because she's like a
super advanced cyborg and she needs
bigger eyes to have more like
cones so she can see better the reason
is anime
the anime their eye budget was all the
way high
budget and when they built the rest of
the robot's body they were like well
just
make everything else small just get the
child model for everything else
is this good or not i'm just looking at
it and it looks weird and i'm like
i guess it's good is it the face of
alita or is it just like everything
about
there's a disconnect happening you know
the problem is you're taking this crazy
wacky anime character and then comparing
that to
everyday humans in everyday world and
stuff and so of course it feels super
out of place despite the fact that
the rendering is like top-notch i feel
like you get over that
really quickly when you're watching the
movie like after like the first five or
ten minutes you kind of just accept
internally that like
she's a cg character because she is
still emoting quite a bit throughout the
whole movie and you believe that it's a
real performance
rosa salazar i think is her name did a
really good job doing all the
facial performance capture and whatnot
the eyes are you know the window to the
soul
we express a lot of emotion through our
eyes and
for how well everybody can read emotion
through eyes
most people don't know explicitly what
to do to make those emotions come out
i say ren draw me angry eyes you might
draw me like you know
slanted brows yep that's what i would do
just like
but if i went wren take the eyebrows out
now draw me angry eyes
the point i'm making is there's a lot
more going on than just the direction of
your eyebrows a lava just has to do with
where your eyelids sit
on your iris if your eyelids are raised
up off your iris at the top that can
give you a very like
rage look your eyelids down a little bit
off the top of your iris but
completely off the bottom like that
gives you like a are you kidding me look
happy is actually both of your eyelids
coming into your iris a little bit
so it's entirely like where those two
skin sleeves on your eye
sit in relative to your pupil and your
iris and that's where a lot of emotion
comes from and alita
her entire character is basically based
on where her eyelids sit
on her eyes so that zapan character
there
it's probably my favorite he's got a
little chin spike he's got a little chin
spike you're right
is it still called a soul patch if a
robot wears it it's like a soul bar
soul bar it's cool seeing all the
different like mechanics inside that
guy's neck move around
that's my favorite part honestly i'm
just trying to figure this out though
like that face looks real
his face looks real you know why sam why
because it is real
that would make sense his face is real
and it's his body that's completely
computer generated
is that little metal soul patch real or
not
it is also real i love that they have
the goatee on them for real
yeah yeah like of all the things to put
real on him it's his goatee
they actually add makeup along the edges
of his face to actually make it look
like it has thickness
i think they actually reprojected the
photography of his face onto a 3d model
yeah to get like all the right shadows
and lighting and whatnot
what a pain in the butt no but it looks
so good what's interesting is when they
recorded these scenes like they had
their
movie camera recording the main angle
and then a bunch of cameras around the
set
recording her as well that they can then
use to triangulate positions
and markers on her suit all these are
like custom sets they're
they're very controlled basically
they're shooting this within a box
so that way each shot can be processed
quickly and efficiently unlike
chappie for example where it's just like
hey let's do guerrilla run and gun
filmmaking and like
put emotion captures in quotes a motion
capture suit on him
which ends up being completely useless
you know what sam's saying is that you
can spend more time on set
and less time in post or more time in
post and less time on set
it depends where your time is more
valuable is it more valuable ahead of
time or after the fact
it's worth noting that when you're in
set especially a big set like one of
these films
and you have a hundred people all making
at least
you know 300 bucks a day most of them
probably making more
it's like a single minute costs hundreds
of dollars
what was the budget for this movie 200
million dollars was the budget of elita
battle angel
so talking about a big budget movie this
movie had the biggest budget of any
movie
ever in the history of movies that's a
complete and utter lie the budget for
this movie was 15 million dollars good
for them
that's how much a movie should be made
for yeah it forces you into all these
like problem-solving situations where
it's like all right we can't afford to
do all of this but we still want to do
something like it
everyone's got a cg person and they're
moving these days
i mean i love how you can actually see
straight through her you definitely
believe that you're looking at a robot
even though it's so human-like it looks
so good
really good what do you guys think is
real hands and face
of that i think her face is real and i
think the actual chest even though it
looks like your costume has also been
replaced so i'm pretty sure
everything except for her face has been
replaced you're
pretty much right you're spot on well
first off i just want to point out the
genius of designing your costume with
little black
separators for what's real and what's
not like on the edges of her wrist she
has like a little black like bracelet
cuff
okay so there's a very easy to find spot
where you can cut off the reel and the
cg
it was actually kind of smart because
there's a grid pattern on this costume
too that allowed them to sneakily motion
track all of it
the face is real and her feet are real
well that's great because that's a point
of contact with the real world and you
want to have that be as realistic as
possible
exactly that was exactly what they're
going for because they knew that all the
things that interact with real life your
feet and your hands
those needed to be real so they weren't
trying to replace those and of course
the face because the face is very hard
to replicate but the rest of it not so
much
they kept the face reel which is like
the main workhorse
of an actor right is the face and so
they're able to get all of like the
emotions of an actual character
but in the body of a robot you might
think like oh
yeah the face was real the hands are
real the feet real easy
do you know some really hard things
there's a tremendous amount of
object tracking going on here it's all
hand animated the average
shot length was eight seconds for this
movie most movies
have an average shot length of like one
second yeah so those like
300 400 robot shots are all eight times
longer than your average like
blockbuster movie shot here's what it
became a headache for this movie
so they need to do the reflections now
usually you just track your
your character and then you set up a you
know a mirror material or whatever
in your program and you get a reflection
it's that easy right it should be
automatic
they shot on anamorphic lenses meaning
that there's slight distortion to the
environment
and also the set has slight distortion
in it meaning
not only do they have to hand track her
in the foreground they then had to go
and
hand track her again in the reflection
yeah
the hardest shot in this film right here
that shot right there that shot this
shot is the hardest shot
the actual shot in the movie is like 16
seconds long when humans are sitting
still
they're actually never sitting still
we're always moving a little bit
i'm so steady right now as still as
possible you're moving
all over the place so ren has had the
most caffeine this morning all right let
me just hold up some of this cool new
tactical reloads merch let me see if i
can hold this still
so you can hold this merch though this
did we plan this plug we didn't plan
this
i'm gonna keep this fast um we just
launched a new merch very high quality
stuff is based on tactical reloads we
also have some other great shirt designs
in our store
quarterdigital.store if you like what we
do here it supports us
please go check it out so here's the
thing it's one thing to like
somebody's running down the hallway
which i said was like the easiest thing
to track
lots of big movements it's easy to just
track things in by hand
somebody's sitting still with their
hands wiggling like a pixel at a time
in different directions that's so
perceptually hard to see frame by frame
if you're tracking it by hand
but in real life when you sing in motion
if it's not there it looks completely
wrong
so you're saying the challenge was
literally just the motion tracking of
her arms
yes not the compositing it or anything
else just the motion tracking
all these little separate pieces that
you're doing the track on the arms not
just the arm but the wrist the hand and
the thumb and the fingers and all the
little digits on them
that's a great example of a shot that
looks completely average
and has a disproportionate amount of
work put into it pretty great vfx in
this
all around obviously the youtube
algorithm is going to keep recommending
these videos to you
but if you don't want a robot
controlling what you watch hit the
subscribe button
and take control of your own fate
[Laughter]
finally a good movie
n64 cover art vibes man wait i'm i'm
confused what's going on right now
they're fighting satan
wow he's like i attack on titan
this is crazy this is so insane the
frame rate just doesn't match in that
shot
oh my goodness really didn't even track
that explosion
it was just placed on there and oh my
god
this is nephew grade visual effects
right now
oh this is my favorite like oh this guy
look at that okay way back in the day
when this movie came out like nico and
myself were working on
vfx in 10th grade in 10th grade i'm
watching this
a movie that came up almost at the same
time we could have done this
it's a lot of work but we could have
done it we could have made it look like
this
so i had i had deus ex machina which is
this video that sam and i made in 10th
grade
do you know how long this shot took to
render all right this shot by the way
took
30 days to render
30 days look at that look at that
oh my god that wasn't so embarrassing
it's not embarrassing it's like
all right get my mp5 with my silencer
take the silencer off this is gonna be a
loud one
he shoots the jet back
obviously i'm just saying we could have
done the visual effects obviously their
choreography is a little bit tighter
look at that this is this is this is
what i'm talking about yeah this is
watching spawn and we're saying we could
have done it just look at this
this is like totally like spawn level oh
he shot my house
they showed me that i got him was that a
burning spawned i got turned into spawn
dude you're just flying there's some
straight up spot over here this is
literally spawn the movie
look at that that's pretty cool how do
you think we did that matrix spin so it
looks like you're either
oh you know what i bet i know you are
resting
on a stool that can spin and you're just
like
holding your arms and legs out and
they're just spinning that and the
camera's staying still
yep that's exactly like yeah i'm
literally just on a green screen on a
stool and niko walks up and spins me you
just match the camera match the camera
to how fast i'm spinning on the stool
anyways spawn our movie basically the
same
but i think ultimately it's like
basically the exact same thing
i don't know i didn't think it was too
bad for a movie that's 22 years old i
think it gets away with it because the
art direction is actually so
awesome and crazy yeah
oh that's that's insane dude like he's
disintegrating and it's all like fluidy
and particularly and then there's a
skeleton and then he's not there at all
honestly as a visual effects artist that
shot
has inspired the way i do action visual
effects
so profoundly i'm not lying like every
single time i do like someone blowing up
in a shot i'm always like
thinking this shot by the way this clip
right now we had a lot of comments
asking for it
if you would like to see a clip please
leave a comment below we read them all
they're great inspiration
so wait didn't they do something special
with how they actually film this on set
wasn't he wearing like a special like
blue suit
yeah that was emitting light so dr
manhattan's you know
giving off blue light the thing is if
you want to do that like fake
like you want to do the blue light after
the fact it's a lot of work and it's
really hard to make it look real it's
easier to have the actual light in the
scene
they had him wear an led suit and he's
wrapped in these leds you can see it
in that shot where he crushes the tank
right there you can see the blue light
shutting out the guy's lab jacket oh
that's true yeah okay
the glow doesn't feel like glow though
it's like a little
dark yeah i think it's too strong in the
blue channel i think that's really the
issue honestly i think
when cameras process color if you have
uh too strong of just blue it doesn't
necessarily register as being bright we
associate brightness with the color
white like regular lights have like a
spectrum
whereas leds will just like give you a
spike in one wavelength we're just kind
of getting like one spike in the blue
wavelength which
if another material doesn't have
something in it to reflect that specific
wavelength it's just not going to
reflect anything
technologically speaking we finally got
to the point where we could actually rig
up leds on a suit for somebody to wear
it like before this point it wasn't even
technologically possible
so it was a great idea it's not really a
critique it's just more like
it's a painterly character in a real
life movie so you can kind of get away
with it not being
100 real it's cool seeing them go
towards a new technological step
today it could be even more strong as in
terms of the visual
impact that would have on you yeah they
got pretty bright leds these days
all right hold up hold up hold up this
show in this entire studio is supported
by our patrons
patreon.com corridor digital we want to
give them a thank you
canadian goose thank you so much philip
oxford astro gg
alan almanza warmaster236
not a canadian spy eddie adolph erenio
guerrero jr
mitch palinski skinky snack glitch
cube james bailey and brian kozick
and thanks to all these people
all of them if you'd like to support
what we do in the studio and you'd like
to be able to vote for clips that we
react to in the show
please consider supporting us on patreon
patreon.com digital there's a link in
the description below
thank you so much to all of you that do
it gives us independence
from the ads on youtube and let's make
what we want to make and see you guys
next week